hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
gmp cleanup routine environmental
monitoring
and 21 cfr part 11 data integrity
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by beckmann culture life sciences
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit beckman.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
or answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now present today's speaker
tony harrison the senior marketing
manager
at beckmannculter for a complete
biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
tony you may now begin your presentation
hello my name is tony harrison i'm a
senior manager with beckmann coulter and
my responsibility
globally to look after our gmp
quality control environmental monitoring
products
now before we start today i'd like to
share
with you a quote from the world health
director general
i'm sure that quote will resonate with
all of us
particularly at this time of the covid
pandemic
so this is the agenda for today's
presentation
i'll touch on the gmps and the world
health
organization rules and regulations for
clean rooms
and also reference the iso standard for
clean rooms
iso 1464-1
and then i'll go on to talk about the
difference between clean room
classification
and routine monitoring because i often
see that
people get confused between the two
and then line up the data integrity
challenges that routine environmental
monitoring
provides for us and finally the last
point in the presentation today i'll
show
how if we can automate that routine
environmental monitoring
we can actually improve our chances of
good data
integrity
so first of all let's take a look at the
gmps and the world health organization
for clean rooms
and the iso standard
now as i said we're all aware right now
um of the search for the coverage
vaccine
and the pharmaceutical industry of
course is racing to find the best
solution for us and vaccines of course
are delivered by injection
like many uh pharmaceutical products and
any parenteral or injectable drug is of
course the biggest risk for us
if they get contaminated because if they
are injected
sorry they are injected directly into
the human body
and when they do that they bypass our
defenses
and any microbial contamination will
cause an infection and possibly blood
poisoning or sepsis
and maybe eat death
this is an extreme example of one of our
probably our most vulnerable and weak
um patients who receive parental
treatment
um it's a premature baby their immune
system is
immunocompromised they can't feed from
the mother
and we have to of course feed them and
give them their medications using
intravenous drip bags
which contain the total parental
nutrition as well as the
the balance of drugs that they need to
keep them alive
now if any contamination gets into these
tpn bags
then it will cause unfortunately almost
certain death
uh for the baby it's got no defenses at
all
and in fact there's been several cases
around the world where this has happened
and
sadly babies on the premature birth
wards have actually died because of
contamination in the tpn bags
and that's why we make injectables or
parenteral products in clean rooms in
order to minimize
the risk of contamination
so here's a recent fairly recent example
of what happens when clean room
contamination control
goes wrong in 2012 in north america the
manufacturing clean room
of a small compounding company became
contaminated
with a spore forming fungus which found
its way into the drug product
now this particular product they were
making was a strong painkiller
which is delivered to the patient by
direct injection into the spinal cord
now 17 000 vials were sadly contaminated
by this event
64 people died from many dr meningitis
as the fungus invaded their nervous
system and made
the um membranes around the brain swell
and 750 more people were infected and
there's no cure for this very painful
infection so if we don't control the
contamination this is the sort of thing
that can happen
so um who are involved in routine
environmental monitoring will notice
that we actually
of course monitor particles in the air
not for bacteria
and the reason for that is that the
biggest challenge for contamination
is the the workers present in the clean
rooms
the average human being is around 100
000 billion bacteria on
and inside their body and we shed over
30 000
skin cells per hour in fact we shed and
replace our entire skin
every month now each of these skin cells
is smaller than the human eye can see
but it carries many microbes which could
fall into and contaminate the
pharmaceutical products
in fact we shed somewhere in the region
of 3.6 kilos of skin cells per year
so the gmp rules and regulations of
course in north america the
cjmp documents covers many aspects of
drug manufacturing and gives best advice
on practices in steroid manufacturing
as well the european and the world
health
share the same gmp annex one and this
defines
exceptional levels of airborne
particulate contamination
for clean rooms for sterile drug
manufacturing and both of these gmps the
european and the north american
and the world health one they all call
the iso standard iso
1464-1 for the methodology
of clean room classification
so let's take a look at the gmp
regulations controlling the
contamination levels in these clean
rooms
now this is the current table for air
particle contaminations in the european
uh gmp annex one and also it's the same
in the guide for stereo manufacturing
from the world health
organization you can see there are four
grades of clean room defined
from the very cleanest the grade a
through to the dirtiest grade d
you can also see that this european gmp
calls for two particle sizes to be
measured
and reported both point five micron
particles
and five micron particles excuse me
now this is the same the world over
except for the north american cgmp
which only calls for 0.5 micron
particles to be measured
and reported
all particle counters report in
particles per cubic meter
and you can see here we're reporting at
rest and in operation
now because we're reporting particles
per cubic meter this can present an area
for potential error
for our routine environmental monitoring
program because the sample taken at each
location is often just one minute
um and with a one cubic foot per minute
counter this one minute sample means
the sample volume taken is just one
cubic foot of air and there are
approximately 35.2
cubic feet in a cubic meter of air so
the customers must sorry
so the users must multiply the count
results by 35.2
to get counts per cubic meter now
of course most particle counters can be
programmed to automatically
make this calculation for the user but
it's another configuration step that the
user has to remember to do
to ensure results are reported correctly
and i've seen it sometimes where
users fail to do that and they're
incorrectly reporting their results
so as i mentioned people are the biggest
source of contamination in the clean
room environment
so of course the workers in clean rooms
have to pass through several different
classes of clean room to enter the
production suite
each area is of course separated by an
airlock and this minimizes the flow of
air from the dirtier outer rooms
into the clean production areas and of
course particle counters after
as i move through the rooms have to be
sanitized
as they pass through each grade of clean
room to another and this is typically
done by spraying them with an industrial
alcohol called
ipa the dirtiest room
is the grade d and staff are required to
change out their outdoor clothes here
and into the clean room clothes
they then pass through to the grade c
preparation area
where the equipment used in production
is prepared
and finally quite normally they are
required to change their clothes again
as they pass into the production area
now generally the grade a production
filling area is protected by a barrier
system
either an isolator or restricted access
barrier or rab
system and this prevents the workers
from entering
into the grade a area and thus
minimizing the chances of contamination
and in the case of uh environment around
the area being
uh grade c for that if there's a barrier
in place
now if there isn't a physical barrier in
place around the filling zone then the
background
to the grade a must be grade b quality
air
so let's take a look at the north
american cgmp document
now this differs to the european and the
world health guidance in that
only mentions one particle size the 0.5
micron particle
however it should be born in mind that
any manufacturer based in north america
wanting to
sell their products outside of north
america to anywhere else in the world
they'll have to count both the 0.5 and 5
microns
as they must be in compliance with the
standards of the country in which they
want to export their products
in the middle of the search for a
vaccine cure for cobit 19
that's the very disease of course that's
keeping us all at home and forcing us to
have a virtual life
this the vaccine manufacturing plants
are in fact a rather
unique subset of the biopharma
production
in that production of a vaccine is
usually done of course
by cultivating high concentrations of
the disease-causing pathogen
in bio-actors they're optimized for cell
health but also they unfortunately will
support microbial growth and
proliferation
at the same time now this gives
manufacturers
additional challenges over and above
other manufacturers of injectable drug
products
extra care must be taken to avoid
contamination bacteria from the
production staff from getting into the
bioreactors because they'll proliferate
and at the same time great care must be
taken not to allow any of the pathogen
itself
from cross-contaminating contaminating
other products which may be manufactured
in separate clean rooms in the same
facility hence vaccine production lines
and the staff and equipment working on
them
are usually kept separated to avoid and
prevent contamination
this means they can't move particle
counters from one clean room to the next
because the particle counter may be
carrying some of the pathogen
and that causes a risk of
cross-contamination into the second
clean room and these challenges are so
well known that the world health
organization
have a dedicated guidance specifically
for environmental monitoring of clean
rooms
in vaccine manufacturing facilities
now i mentioned already that both the
european gmp and the north american cgmp
tell the reader to refer to the
classification procedures laid down in
the iso standard
iso 1464-1
now the iso standard is not a gmp
document
and is actually designed to give
guidance rather than mandate
but the fact that it is referenced by
the gmps gives it the same status as a
gmp document
for those manufacturers regulated
now the iso standard has a wide range of
clean room classes
covering particle sizes from 0.1 to 5
microns
and the number of particles per cubic
meter for each meter for each class is
defined
in the table itself
now the idea is the user must decide
what particle sizes they're interested
in
and how clean the clean room must be and
then they choose a subset of the clean
room class and particle size from the
iso table
gmp has decided the particle sizes of
interest
are 0.5 and 5 microns
and you can see for grade b at rest the
number of particles
match exactly the iso 5 in
grade an important thing to note in
in the 2015 version of this iso standard
it doesn't specify the number of
particles at 5 microns
for iso class 5 however
users who are regulated to european gmp
or world health gmp
must comply with the gmp rules and so
they are required to measure five micron
particles as well
so the fact they're no longer mentioned
in the iso standard
doesn't mean that you don't have to
measure them if you're following
eu gmp or world health organization gmp
you still have to monitor them
all right so that's the rules and
regulations
so let's take a look now
[Music]
at the different classrooms sorry clean
rooms and
classification and routine monitoring
so they're two very different things
classification and monitoring
portable particle counts of course a use
of both application
um and the first is classification of
course
very different from monitoring as i said
and the classification process is
defined very clearly
in the iso standard whereas
it's a responsibility of the user to
define the routine environmental
monitoring programs specific to their
own production process
product and the clean room so this
absence of any specific
guidance for routine monitoring
locations and frequencies
often leads the user to
wonder what they should be doing and
they the users themselves have to take
ownership of the decision where the
environmental monitoring
is done routinely and it must be based
on a risk assessment
of their specific production process
their product and the clean room itself
now clean room classification focuses on
the clean room itself so
in this classification we're not looking
at risk to the product we're just trying
to check that the clean room itself
is performing to the target cleanliness
class
now it's very well described in iso 146
44-1
and typically carried out every six or
12 months depending on your
standard operating procedure
now this is just an example of a clean
room here it's not meant to be
prescriptive but you can see how the iso
standard tells the user to calculate the
correct number of locations according to
the size of the clean room
and then it tells the user to lay the
sampling locations out and then
evenly distributed grid pattern across
the room
according to the iso standard there's no
requirement to take a sample where the
product is at risk of airborne
contamination
because it's just checking the room
itself
in this example following the iso
standard means there are no samples
taken in the areas where product
may be at risk for instance the
scrambler table
the filling zone the stopping zone or
the capping station itself
now we come to cleanroom environmental
monitoring
now for monitoring there are no hard and
fast rules
just that the user must make a risk
assessment of where the product may be
exposed
to airborne contamination in the
manufacturing process
and set sampling locations at these
points for their routine environmental
monitoring program
so if we now take another look at the
example i just gained
for cleanroom classification
in this theoretical example if we now
look at monitoring
the user has taken a look at their
manufacturing process and decides on
those locations where the product may be
at risk
and laid out their sampling program
appropriately
and you'll notice that these sampling
locations for routine environmental
monitoring
are in very different locations to those
used for classification
so please avoid using the same locations
you do for classification for routine
monitoring it's not how it should be
done
so this whole webinar is about class
clean room monitoring and data integrity
challenges that it provides so
let's take a look at that whole process
now of course as we well know routine
environmental monitoring
clean rooms is typically a very manual
process
involving the collection of thousands of
samples each month using portable
particle counters
typically there are very many manual sop
steps to be followed in the typical
routine environmental monitoring
program and the first step of course is
for the technician to make sure that
using the correct version
of the environmental monitoring sop
then as they follow the sampling map in
the sop they have to go to each sample
location
and then manually type the location name
into the particle counter
via an on-screen keyboard
and next they have to configure the
counter to sample for the correct amount
of time
and for the correct number of samples
according to the sop
for each location most people
standardize on the same sampling for
every location but
in some cases different sample locations
are used
and so that the counter configuration
has to change
and next they print the sample results
from each location
from the counter and hand write comments
onto the printout and sign it with their
name
to make it attributable to them
and at the end of each day they
photocopy all of the
printouts and then manually type the
results
from every piece of paper into an
electronic record
and of course finally the electronic
record is reviewed by the supervisor to
ensure
a that all the samples have been taken
and b that the data in the electronic
record matches the printout so it's
incredibly manual process with thousands
of samples
lots of pieces of paper and manual data
transcriptions
and the opportunity for human error to
creep in and impact the integrity of the
data is very
high indeed
now the fda are aware of this and in
their 2018 guidance on 21 cfr part 11
their question and answers paper that
they published
they stated that in recent years they've
increasingly observed cgmp violations
involving data integrity during their
inspections
and these violations of course have led
to numerous regulatory actions including
warning letters import alerts and even
consent decrees
and what they've said is that firms
should be uh implementing meaningful and
effective strategies to manage their
data integrity risks
based on their knowledge of their
understanding sorry their knowledge and
their understanding of their process
and also the the use of technologies to
help them with that
now in their 2018 question and answer
session
uh paper sorry on interpreting their
data integrity guidance they introduced
for the first time
the acronym alcoa saying that a good
electronic record
or sorry in response to a question about
what a good electronic record looks like
they said
should be attributable which is the
first day in our code to the person
taking the sample they said it should be
legible which
implies handwriting is probably not the
right way to go
and it should be made contemporaneously
or at the same time that
sample is taken rather than
later at a later time from paper
printouts and of course the record
should be the original record
and the data it contains should be
accurate
so let's take a look now on how we can
automate our routine environmental
monitoring programs to help
improve the data integrity and reduce
human error
with this particular particle counter on
the screen here
you can see the accuracy is improved
because the sop
sampling map from the sop used on that
site
itself has been uploaded into the
counter itself
and it's used to create an interactive
version of the sop
sampling map in the counter itself
so the technician follows the map to the
next sampling location and simply taps
on the location on the map the counter
then automatically configures itself
according to the sop
the accuracy is improved now because
there's nothing the technician has to do
other than tap the run sample there's no
manual configuration or manual data
entry required
and accuracy is further improved as the
sop
version control is now done inside the
counter itself so you can see this
sop here it's version one and it's
released and active in the counter
the administrators can log on remotely
to the particle counter using a web
browser there's no special software
required and they can configure an sop
and then
release it using their electronic
signature into the counter
the final electronic record is actually
created contemporaneously
inside the counter itself the counter
can give you paper printouts but there's
no need for paper printouts anymore
you get the electronic record straight
from the particle counter using
wi-fi or using uh wired ethernet
and the record contains a reference to
the sop name
and the version number that was used on
the day so
you know you're using the right eso
version of the sop
the user signs on using microsoft active
directory so
there's an electronic signature applied
to the record
you can enter the production batch id to
tie the sample to
the production batch the location name
is automatically populated because it's
pre-programmed in the counter
the date and time is of course captured
as is the configuration
used in the counter sampling results and
the sample volume
any alert and action alarms are also
recorded in the electronic record and
user comments are also recorded in the
electronic record
as well
to make sure that the records are
accurate there is a review and
approve workflow in the counter itself
so the administrator or supervisor can
log into the particle counters over
their
company network just using a web browser
there's no specialist software
required and the daily sampling can be
reviewed and approved for accuracy
remotely via web riser creating an
electronic record with an electronic
signature attached ready for export
straight from the counter
via ethernet or wi-fi
and the final workflow functionality in
the counter
that helps with improve or the accuracy
of the results or certainly underpin the
accuracy
is the integrated audit trail and the
audit trail contains
the user id of the person running the
instrument
which as i said is controlled using
microsoft active directory
um it can also contain success and
failure of user logins when they logged
in when they logged out
when the sample started when the sample
was completed
if somebody adds a new user or changes
the user groups that's all recorded
there as well as is
changing a password as well for a local
user um if
users are removed that's captured as is
the calibration
events sops can be changed in there by
the administrator only
and it records any changes to the sops
or updates to new versions
in the audit trail um and of course um
the instrument instrument configuration
changes are also recorded
in the audit trail so you can see with
this automated workflow we've taken out
a lot of the human error
that causes those data integrity issues
that we have
and that brings me to the end
of my session today i hope you found it
informative
i'd like to open up the floor now to
answer any questions that you might have
thank you tony for your informative
presentation we will now
start the q a portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
okay tony your first question
is user says thank you for your
presentation
there are many particle counters
available on the market
please can you summarize the key
difference with your met one
3400 plus and how it helps improve data
integrity
what makes the 3400 plus difference
well thank you for attending today i
appreciate the question
there are actually really four clear
differences here
first and foremost really is the
interactive sop
map on the screen and this removes the
need for the
technician to manually configure the
counter and of course
if you're removing manual steps you're
avoiding errors in the data
or potential human error calling it
causing the errors
the second thing is the electronic
record itself is produced
contemporaneously or at the time you
make the measurement
inside the counter so this avoids data
errors that can occur when
you you're manually transcribing from
the paper records which we typically
have
into electronic format the third point i
guess would be the accuracy of the data
which is confirmed by the built-in
review and approved workflow
which allows the supervisor to remotely
review the data
just using a web browser and to apply an
electronic signature to the data
and finally of course the process of
capturing the environmental monitoring
samples can be reviewed
itself to ensure there's no errors using
the built-in
audit trail
great thank you all right your next
question you show a remote review
an approved feature for the met one what
software is required to ask
to access the counter remotely and how
do you guarantee
security that's a good question thank
you
so in fact you don't need any software
to access the counter remotely
as long as the counter is connected to
your company network you can control
sop versions and review and approve data
from your office
simply using a web browser such as
google chrome
security is assured as the user who logs
on remotely must
use their microsoft active directory
controlled username and password
via the web browser interface in order
to browse the counter remotely so that's
how we keep it secure
okay it looks like we have time for one
last question i can see that microsoft
active directory can help records be
attributable but why is it better than
usernames and passwords created in the
counter itself
yeah that's a good question really and
the reason that
typically regulators are looking for you
to use microsoft active directory
it gives you much more security you can
choose not to enable this feature and
create local usernames and passwords in
the counter itself but
the idea behind using active directory
that it's
a enforces the users to use the level of
complexity defined
by their corporate id for their
passwords and usernames
and b and i think this is probably the
most significant reason why it's
encouraged the use of microsoft active
directory is encouraged because
it stops the use of generic passwords
that all the technicians use on the
counters
because they don't want to remember yet
another password i mean
as you can imagine in a fleet of
particle counters it won't take long
before the password
use on the on one counter gets out of
sync with all the others
and you end up needing different
passwords for different particle
counters
so it has been observed quite common
practice for teams to use a generic
password a single generic password
for all the particle counters so all the
team uses the same generic password and
of course
that removes the traceability of the
sampling
uh completely so using active directory
avoids this
as you only have to a first of all
remember the same password
used to log on to your company computer
and it be it stops the use of these
generic passwords
thank you again tony for your time today
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we go
uh no i i thank you for the opportunity
to present today and and thank you to
the audience for attending
i hope that was informative and if there
are any more
questions perhaps you'd be kind enough
to forward them on to me i know we
haven't got time today but if you can
forward them on to me that would be
great and i'll try and answer them by
email afterwards
thank you we'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor beckman coulter
life sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
like tony mentioned any questions we did
not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by speaker via
the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
and labors will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
thank you goodbye